it's on like Dom is right copyright
[Music]
Donkey Kong Country Returns took long
enough so I was a huge Donkey Kong
Country fan back in the day and for all
intents and purposes I still am I still
happen for the Game Boy Advance Donkey
Kong fun then fun now and now we have
Donkey Kong Country Returns for the Wiis
so how does it hold up I'm not going to
keep you guys in suspense it's friggin
awesome they have brought back most
everything that was great about Donkey
Kong Country back in the day and they've
added to it and really awesome ways and
when I say most everything that means
most everything as in the good I've
smoked through that level that was easy
yet fun and the bed I pushed John the
great and classic music from the
original Donkey Kong Country is back in
Donkey Kong Country Returns in some way
shape or form
you're gonna recognize most of the
tracks in this game it has some new
original music but it does have the
classic also and of course this game has
bonus levels and secrets that keep you
sniffing around the levels for hours and
at the end of the level it tells you how
many secrets there were - how many
secrets you actually got and it always
ends like 3 out of 5 are you kidding me
I'd sniff through that level I hid
everything apparently I'm a very intense
gamer not gonna lie some of these
secrets they're pretty well hidden even
if you find them finding the secrets and
beat in the bonus levels two very
different things
Diddy's in the game and he's playable
and 2 player and 2 player man he's got
the jetpack he's got the little peanut
gun not gonna like give me the
two-player controller did he's awesome
getting stuck with a two-player
controller in this game is not like
great you just hugged Mario awesome I I
can't be Mario yeah you got the three
others pick whoever oh hey oh my mistake
those are great choices what was I
thinking if you took all the
testosterone in Luigi and the two toads
and mix it together it would not
remotely equal half the testosterone
that's in Mario's baby that's hanging
out on Yoshi's back you sound pretty mad
I'm not giving up Mario dude and did
he's in the game in 1 player mode but
you don't play as him you play as Donkey
Kong did he just piggy backs on you so
you can use his jetpack to hover around
like peach and Mario too and the levels
in this game look great I mean so many
times I felt like I was on the Krait in
Disneyland or something like Pirates of
the Caribbean or the Indiana Jones ride
actually that's exactly what it is if
you've been to Disneyland you'll
understand if they took the set of
Pirates of the Caribbean the ride and
Indiana Jones the ride and mixed it with
Tarzan the
world or whatever Donkey Kong Country
Returns and they use the graphics really
well I mean for all intents and purposes
it's a 2d platformer side scroller game
but on quite a few of the levels things
in the background are flying towards you
that you have to dodge and then you get
into a barrel and it shoots you into the
background and that's the continuation
of the level I mean it makes for some
really cool and unique levels a great
game mechanic and an all-around really
fun game and the kremlings aren't the
bad guys in this game you got to fight
the hypnotic tiki torch people whoever
they are I only complain about the game
is the animal buddies from the other
games they're not really in this game I
mean Randy's in it a couple times not
that often but the other ones know the
nostalgic side of me wants to see them
back at the logical side of me knows
that you have enough moves anyway you
don't need them so this game is great
yeah shooters and action games they're
fun also but if you're one of those
people who are gonna be like Donkey Kong
Country you [ __ ] serious
only one kind of game worth playing they
have guns explosions you're doing
yourself a disservice if you love New
Super Mario Brothers and/or like Donkey
Kong Country back in the day not getting
this game would be like being an action
game junkie and not playing God of War I
wouldn't understand that this game is
great go check it out even though
sometimes you're gonna be like I said
hit the ground not that I've done that
but if you like what you've seen here
you want to see more than click right
here to see more
[Music]